but our next guest is concerned that
attempts to rewrite history
and cancel out aspects of our culture
and our values may be our downfall
please welcome the author of how to
destroy america in three easy steps
and the number one conservative podcast
in the country
ben shapiro ben thanks for being here
thanks for having me
so look here's my concern you lay this
out really well in your book
um are you concerned that if folks on
the left read it they understand what
what the right is trying to do or is
that is it just too big of an
issue for you that you're not worried
about that well i mean i'm not really
worried that the left is going to
suddenly discover the roots of american
philosophy i think that they don't care
about that what they truly care about
is is pushing their view of america as
innately flawed
as destructive as rooted in racism
bigotry and evil
and they're making the seductive case
that they're going to replace all of the
founding fathers
ideas with a very different set of ideas
ideas that are
rooted instead in the idea of
entitlement in the idea of equality of
outcome rather than equality before the
law or equality of rights
and there's a certain seductive appeal
to that i mean i talk at length in the
book about
the the ideas what i call
disintegrationist that if they didn't
have appeal they wouldn't be winning
right now they do have appeal the appeal
lies largely in the idea that personal
responsibility doesn't exist that you
can always blame your own failures on
the system
but the system itself needs to be
changed in order to maximize your own
personal profit your own personal
pleasure
and that all of history's flaws can be
identified in structures of today that
have to be torn down
that's there's some something seductive
about that obviously otherwise it
wouldn't be quite so popular
yeah something i find really interesting
about your book is that you actually
don't refer to people as on the
right or on the left why is that uh the
reason is because i don't think that
this is a purely right-left phenomenon
meaning that
there are a lot of people who identify
as liberals who are not actually
of the hard left but that's a
distinction that many liberals won't
make themselves they tend to think of
themselves as of the left so instead by
creating distinction between folks who i
think want the country to hold together
with fundamental principles rooted in
the declaration of independence and
people who
fundamentally want to remake the entire
country and destroy all of those
institutions
i think there are some people who
consider themselves part of the left who
actually will find themselves in the
unionist camp i was hoping to make the
decision more difficult for a lot of
people who may disagree with me on tax
rates
or the proper role of government and
health care i want to make it easier for
them to embrace founding principles and
a lot of the things i think they already
believe
and more difficult for them to simply
walk away from the argument
ben as a conservative i'll admit that
some days i feel like we're losing the
culture war
you see everything else getting
cancelled out names getting changed
brands
dumping their lifelong brand how do can
conservatives turn the tide
well i think that in the end if things
don't get better
pretty quickly conservatives are going
to be left playing mutually assured
destruction with the left and i think
what that will probably mean
is that conservatives will have to found
their own companies that are in exactly
the same arenas as some of these other
major corporations
and simply withdraw their purchasing
power from places they disagree with now
i don't prefer that i would prefer that
we all be able to buy the shoes
that we want to buy and that we not care
about the political affiliations of ceos
but if the left is going to play this
game where they destroy companies based
on the political viewpoints of the ceo
or they're going to go after anybody who
has a bad old tweet from 15 years ago or
a not so bad old tweet from 15 minutes
ago
then conservatives are going to be left
with no ability to even have a
conversation you're going to end up with
with two essentially strata in american
society one conservative
and one of the left i i prefer that we
not go that way but i i'm
having a hard time seeing how we don't
considering corporate america's
willingness to simply mirror the policy
priorities and rhetoric of the left
you know someone else that's mirroring
that conversation i feel like speaking a
lot of plot issues lately
is joe biden um it seems like he's
getting away with all the tough
questions he asked if he should defund
the police he says no but we should just
restructure
funding is this going to come back to
bite him do you think
or is this gonna work for him in the end
uh because he's as we know
kind of hiding out well i mean so far
it's working
he's he's lucky in so far as he has two
factors one covid means that he doesn't
actually have to demonstrate any sort of
energetic level on the campaign trail
because there is no campaign trail so
that actually benefits them quite a lot
second is the fact that this has turned
into a referendum on president trump
as opposed to a referendum on biden
biden is uniquely non-vulnerable
to the question of of a referendum on
his on himself personally
he's not alive it turns out that it's
hard to beat a dead horse i've said
before
and because biden is relatively
inoffensive he's relatively well liked
people kind of know who he is
and they don't see him as threatening
president trump's attempts to paint him
is threatening
are really not falling with any sort of
with any sort of
serious impact right now that may change
depending on who he picks for vp
if he picks somebody who is perceived as
radical for vp he picks como harris for
example
for vp uh if he picks uh if he were to
pick stacey abrams which he's not going
to but if he were to
then that would obviously give trump a
lot to campaign against because then
every commercial is just
biden saying i'm a transitional figure
and then you make the commercial about
the vp candidate
hey ben in the book you talk a lot about
our culture and our history a recent
poll
in the wall street journal and nbc news
looked at 900 voters
and they found that 56 percent agreed
that american society is
racist of that 82 percent of those
who agreed were democrats 30 republicans
and 45 independents
we're also seeing polls about people you
know our founding fathers being bad
people
is that i mean this gets to the heart of
what your book is about we are erasing
our history
the rewriting of american history from a
glorious story of founding principles
not fully
achieved or live up to in their time and
then gradually achieved overtime through
the heroism of figures black
and white and through the heroism of of
presidents and common people that's the
story of the united states the story of
the greatest most prosperous freest and
most tolerant nation in the history of
the world
that story has been replaced with the
1619 project howard's unification of
american history where american history
is instead viewed
through the lens of various oppressions
and exploitations
and that obviously has had a pretty
major impact i do think that that wall
street journal poll showing 56
of americans saying american society is
racist i think that people know what
pollsters expect them to say
i really do i think that the the stat
that shows that is the 45
of americans saying american society is
racist my guess is that that number in
actuality is a fair bit lower you're not
going to get canceled these days for
saying american society is racist you're
gonna get canceled for saying american
society isn't racist
i think everybody sort of knows where
their bread is buttered culturally ben
let me ask you this you are a big
baseball fan
one what do you think of the current
season the rules and the way
everything's being played
and two about this migration of kneeling
that started in the nfl and is now going
on in the mlb
i think the corporations are attempting
to avoid the controversial by being
controversial
i think that they are they're sort of i
would say relying on conservatives to
continue consuming their product
even if they are mildly offended by the
product while knowing that if they don't
virtue signal to the left the left
actually turns off the tv the left is
much better at this
than the right is uh i think what they
don't understand is that a lot of people
are going to turn off the tv i'm an mlb
tv subscriber
i have very little interest in watching
games if i'm going to be preached to
about
the idea that america's systemically
racist in the middle of a baseball game
that is not why i turn into sports in
the first place i think there are a lot
of people who think like me
and i think there will be some blow back
there as far as you know the kind of
coveted rules that they're applying
right now
it seems to me that the media have very
little leg to stand on suggesting that
it is perfectly fine to gather by the
thousands to riot in portland or riot in
seattle
but if we sit every third seat at a
ballpark in the open air in the
summertime that this
poses some sort of massive threat in
terms in terms of covet
i get it i do um but i think that that
is is overblown in terms of what the
actual risk factors are the same way
that the media were blowing out of
proportion
the risk factors for being on beaches
early on in the pandemic
i i think it would be foolhardy for them
to cancel the mlb season although i will
say that the players union
uh obviously made this very difficult in
a way they didn't for the nba or the nfl
by saying we're not going to play inside
a bubble instead we're going to travel
all over the country if you if you do
that you know they're going to be
coveted cases but you also know that
mlb players are disproportionately young
and healthy and that covet
disproportionately affects people who
are not young and healthy
you know ben something else i just
recently saw is that joe rogan
is moving out of la and moving to texas
i know that you're in l.a he said he's
moving out of there because there's too
many bums he wants more freedom
uh kovid's running rampant uh you live
there
what what's your take on on la are you
happy
no i mean i think that joe's right i
mean this place has turned into a trashy
but
it's it it's amazing you know but barack
obama talked about a green new deal here
in la we've been using infrastructure
dollars to pay for porta-potties under
the freeways for the various homeless
encampments we have the brown new deal
out here it's very exciting stuff
uh yeah l-a-l-a in my lifetime i mean
i've you know lived my entire life in
l.a and it used to be
a pretty i wouldn't say it was ever a
really well-run city but it was at least
fairly clean
uh now the the levels of trash on the
streets open needles on the streets
uh the the level of um of homelessness
is exorbitant
and it's not good for homeless people
either i mean if you are if you're
mentally ill or drug addicted living on
the street you know with risk of covid
that seems like not a very great living
arrangement to me
la has basically decided to run itself
directly into the ground so i i
definitely hear where joe's coming from
and
with a 13.3 state income tax rate and
joe making 100 million bucks from
spotify
i can certainly see why uh he's saying
to himself why am i paying 13 million
dollars to the state of california so i
can't
so i can have open needles outside my
office yeah
that's a pretty big incentive ben let me
brag on you for one second you graduated
from high school
if i get my fact straight two years
early you graduated laude
from harvard law school you had two
books published by the time you were 17.
i believe this current book is your 11th
or 12th what
what was it that inspired you to do all
of this
at that age and frankly do it against
the grain right at 17 18
i was just looking to get outside and
have fun never mind espouse conservative
values
you were out there writing a book
starting a a
you know talk on on morning talk what
what was the driving force behind you is
it a parent
is there something inherent that makes
you i mean what got you there
my parents were always very encouraging
they always loved the fact that i was
into history and into politics and
and they always surrounded me with
people of a variety of different
viewpoints uh with whom i could discuss
issues um honestly i i thought when i
was younger and i was going to college i
thought that i was going to double major
in music and genetic science because i
was a classical violinist at the time
uh and uh and when i got on college
campuses and and i saw at ucla the the
ucla daily bruin
i opened it up one of the first days i
was there there was an editorial
comparing
ariel sharon then the prime minister of
israel to adaf nazi
and i walked in i said i'd like to write
a counter to that and so it began so
it was mostly just being upset with with
falsehood being purveyed
uh in in major newspapers because daily
burn had like 16 000 people reading it
every day
um and it sort of moved on from there
and and just as far as getting things
done
i mean as you can tell i have a pretty
high rpm and uh the motor keeps running
although my kids are doing
their best to to take the energy out of
me for sure i have three under the age
of seven so
yeah i i know that i know that feeling
you know when i was in the white house
even when i left
there were some pretty nasty things said
about me um and
i admit you know that they still sting
here and there you you've been
very out there with your thoughts and
your beliefs and your values
um and some pretty nasty things have
been said about you
uh the one that i think is the most
ironic is when people call you
anti-semitic or nazi
as an orthodox jew and someone who's
very well versed in your religion i
think that one takes the cake
do those criticisms still sting
sure i mean i'm a human being and just
like everybody's a human being you think
that your skin is thick enough and
and your skin is never thick enough to
not at least feel mildly irritated by
the overwhelming waves of hatred that
come and it's usually intermittent you
know i tend to
trend on twitter i would say once every
three weeks on average uh and when that
happens it's it's you know irritating
but the good news is that i've
uninstalled twitter from my phone so i
just don't have to pay attention to it
so
that that's kind of the only way to deal
with it is to build the bubble around
yourself with people you trust
while stilling allowed the people the
people you trust really have to be able
to give you
honest criticism the key is to
distinguish between people giving you
honest criticism and people just
looking to tear you down yeah that's i i
can totally get that
hey ben thanks for being here i
appreciate you making so much time
congratulations on your next book i
imagine within six seven months we're
going to see the next one and
congratulations on being a great dad
i appreciate it thanks so much